I'm Russ Altman I'm a professor of
bioengineering genetics medicine and by
courtesy computer science at Stanford
University I came to Stanford in 1983
from to do a medical school and a PhD an
MD PhD little did I know that this was
going to be life-changing for me because
I got interested in the field of
biomedical informatics and obviously
Stanford being in the middle of Silicon
Valley has always been a leader in that
field I wasn't thinking biomedical
informatics when I made the decision to
come to Stanford but it was obviously
incredibly fortuitous and so I've been
privileged of doing medical school and
then my residency in medicine and then
joining the faculty to do research and
how information Sciences can impact our
understanding of medicine and how to
best deliver medicine the promise of
pharmacogenomics which I'm very excited
about is that someday we'll be able to
do a genome sequence on a patient early
in their life and then from then on when
their providers need to use a medication
for any reason they can refer to this
database and make sure that they choose
the drugs that are most likely to work
well and least likely to have bad side
effects that's something we can't do
right now so the field of biomedical
informatics was always in my interest
and then when I saw genomics and
pharmacogenomics and how my training as
a physician and my training as a
computational person could come together
in projects where this isn't this
knowledge was jointly useful it just was
a perfect match and that's where we got
involved in the farm gkb project which
is the source of my passion about
pharmacogenomics
you